willkommen zur letzten vorlesung in
diesem semester zum thema philosophie
der digitalität heute geht es um einen
rückblick und zugleich um einen ausblick
man könnte sagen die ganze vorlesung war
doch ein großer ausblick habe ich glaube
das stimmt nicht wir haben immer wieder
versucht bezüge zu anderen disziplinen
und zur vergangenheit auch eher zu
stellen ja es geht jetzt darum dass ich
versuche die
vorlesung kurz zu rekapitulieren und
auch immer wieder verweise herzustellen
auf vergangenen sitzungen und anschluss
gibt es ein thematischen ausblick auf
die frage ist das metaversum sie werden
das wort schon mal gehört haben etwa die
zukunft des internets
des internets als eines virtuellen
handlungsraum ist dann will ich noch mal
die frage nach der virtuellen realität
als realität aufwerfen und onlive als
lebensform auch im zusammenhang mit dem
metaversum diskutieren und ich werde
dann ein methodologischen ausblick geben
der die frage betrifft inwiefern eine
philosophie der digitalität wie sie im
zentrum dieser vorlesung stand und heute
auch noch steht als eine philosophische
disziplin neben anderen disziplinen wie
zum beispiel erkenntnistheorie wie zum
beispiel moralphilosophie angesehen
werden kann oder auch nicht jedenfalls
wie sich ein mit philosophie der
digitalität zu anderen fusion zwischen
disziplin erhält ja noch mal kurz zur
wiederholung das sollte eigentlich jetzt
das ziel der vorlesung gewesen zahlen
das zu zeigen was ist eine philosophie
der digitalität ich habe die these
vertreten dass ich philosophie der
digitalität von soziologischen
psychologischen technologischen und
ökonomischen zu gehen zum phänomene
digitalisierung unterscheidet und dass
die philosophie der digitalität kein
alternativer zugang zu diesen
interdisziplinären zugang ist zur
digitalisierung sondern dass sie wie es
die philosophie meinen augen tun sollte
dass sie die anderen interdisziplinären
zugänge fundiert das heißt sie klärt die
jeweils zugrundeliegenden begriffe
digital analog virtuelle realität
virtualität internet immersion raumzeit
handlungen ethik usw diese begriffe
claire zieht die bei den anderen
disziplin häufig ziemlich ungeklärt als
selbstverständlich vorausgesetzt werden
müssen weil einfach die disziplin sich
nicht in diesen grundbegriffen befassen
das scheint menowin ist anliegen der
philosophie zu sein und eben auch mit
blick auf die frage nach einer
philosophie der digitalität ja jetzt
hatte ich ganz zu beginn der vorlesung
die frage aufgeworfen wenn es eine
kultur der digitalität gibt so für felix
stalder argumentiert gibt es dann
vielleicht gab es dann vielleicht eine
kultur der elektrizität in beiden fällen
handelt es sich und paradigmen um
technologische paradigmen die gewaltige
bedeutet für die gesamte wirtschaft
gesellschaft auch die geschichte haben
und ich bin fündig geworden und zwar bei
diesem buch von christa garcia das
intensive leben eine moderne obsession
hier schreibt dieser autor dass die
elektrifizierung
ungeheure
ungeheuren einfluss hatte auch auf die
geistesgeschichte weil sie eben mit
energie mit dem energetischen
ganz eng zusammenhängen ist insofern
sich auch als hauptfigur der moderne wie
spannende these wenn die
elektrifizierung
das energische bedeutet dann kann man
sich die frage stellen was bedeutet dann
bitteschön die digitalisierung
ich hätte ein paar angebote
vernetzung und beschleunigung damit
ziehe ich mich auf dieses buch digitale
aufklärung auf der sich auch noch
genauer zu sprechen kommen
ja also hier ganz wichtig technologische
phänomene können durchaus auch
philosophen bedeutsam sein und so war es
mit der elektrifizieren und so ist es
und wird es mit der digitalen ich hatte
schon erwähnt kultur der digitalität von
felix stalder ganz wichtiges buch ist
keine philosophie der digitalität aber
es legt den boden für eine befassung aus
der perspektive der philosophie und
stalder hat er dafür argumentiert dass
wir seit dem jahr 2000 verschiedene
entwicklungen
kennen können die gemeinsam eine
kulturelle konstellation ergeben und so
eine kohärente kultur der digitalität er
spricht nicht von kulturen von der
kultur formen
ja diese drei begriffe die dafür ganz
wichtig sind referenziert
gemeinschaftlichkeit algorithmen zitiert
wir haben im rahmen dieser vorlesung
verschiedene diese themen behandelt wir
haben uns mit dem internet befasst was
ja alles vernetzt das betrifft sowohl
die referenz i tät als auch die
gemeinschaftlichkeit und wir haben uns
auch intensiv mit der künstlichen
intelligenz befasst aus
erkenntnistheoretische perspektive aber
auch aus ästhetischer perspektiven und
das ist hier mit algorithmen zieht
bezeichnet dann war es ganz wichtig auf
dem begriff des mediums zu reflektieren
der ganz eng mit dem thema
digitalisierung oder digitalität
zusammenhängt hier war marshall mit
loren die bezugs figur
der anhand der gedruckten schrift das
buch dokumentiert
hat er sich dabei nicht nur um eine
technologie handelt sondern dass es
überhaupt
die ganze gesellschaft fort also man
darf es nicht zu eng fassen das medium
des mediums strahlt immer aus und hier
auch noch ein gutes buch für unsere
vorlesung understanding media die
extensions auf mehr erweiterung des
menschen
und auch hier ist ganz wichtig dass das
medium nicht nur instrumentell verwendet
wird verstanden wird sind das als eine
erweiterung von uns selbst angesehen
wird und sofern es alle möglichen
anderen kontexten noch prägt
dann habe ich noch ein weiteres buch
gebracht luciano flori die die vierte
revolution wie die info sphäre unser
leben verändert und er argumentiert dass
die neuen medien umwelt gestaltende
anthropologische soziale und interpret
aktive kräfte geworden sind
da kann ich vorbehaltlos zustimmen sie
modifizieren alle möglichen bereiche
unseres lebens die haben lebens
wirkliche bedeutung und insofern
verlieren sie ihren instrumentalen
charakter vielleicht sogar das war
jedenfalls meine these ihren medialen
charakter weil sie zu einer eigenen
realität werden und nicht nur zu einem
mittel der vermittlung
dann muss man natürlich auch wenn man
sich mit den neuen medien befasst eine
medienkritik ganz nehmen hier aus sicht
der hirnforschung von manfred spitzer
sehr provokativen titel digitale demenz
wie wir uns unsere kinder den verstand
bringen hier der verschiedene
bildschirme unübersichtlichkeit chaos
spielkonsolen ein weiteres buch mit dem
titel selber krank wie das
digitalisierte leben unsere gesundheit
ruiniert cyber krank es gibt ein
weiteres buch cyber place ist von tobias
will ich kann das kaum noch zu sprechen
es gibt einen computer spielt das reimt
sich auf cyber krank das heißt cyberpunk
und ist im letzten jahr wohl letzte
erschien auch spannend und dann gibt es
noch ein buch die smartphone epidemie
gefahren für gesundheit bildung und
gesellschaft man sieht hier also hier
wird ein zugang gewählt zu den neuen
medien ganz stark von einer
gesundheits perspektive man muss
natürlich auch hier mit den kritiken
immer kritisch umgehen sicherlich sind
darin waren punkte enthalten aber sie
setzen ein bestimmtes medienbild voraus
ein bestimmtes medium konzept und und
diese medienkonzept möchte ich mich
jedenfalls als philosophischer
perspektive abgrenzen so dass der medien
begriffe wie ich ihn vertrete nicht von
dieser kritik von spitzer betroffen weil
er immer schon leicht normativen ich
werde darauf noch näher eingehen
digitalität bedeutet dass
digitalisierung nicht unter rezessions
gesichtspunkten betrachtet wird nicht
und der konsum
betrachtungen
thematisch wird sondern digitalität
bedeutet dass digitalisierung sinnvoll
in unsere lebenswelt eingang findet mit
dem sinnvoll ist schon ein normativität
angezeigt die von vornherein diese
ganzen durchaus berechtigte kritik
entkräften kann weil sie gar nicht davon
betroffen sind
hier noch ein interessantes buch post
digitalmedien kritik im einzelnen ist
wundert als sie sehen es gibt sowohl
eine bewegung die versucht die neuen
medien philosophisch zu profilieren auch
zu verteidigen zu etablieren und es gibt
eine wie immer wie in allen dingen gibt
es eine gegenbewegung
auch so was wie digitalen minimalismus
gibt es im digital detox gibt
verschiedene bewegungen und man muss wie
ich finde einen gesunden mittelweg
finden vor allem aus philosophischer
perspektive
hier wird das smartphone schon mit
rauchen in verbindung gesetzt also hier
wird wieder eine sucht perspektive wie
bei manfred spitzer auf die neuen medien
geworfen ich finde das nicht adäquat
hier liegt natürlich ein anderer medien
begriff zugrunde ein medien begriff im
sinne des konsum mediums und ich glaube
beim solchen medien begriff müssen wir
hinaus kind wenn wir philosophisch
sinnvoll über digitalisierung reden
wollen
insofern finde ich dass wir eine metall
kritik der neuen medien unternehmen
müssen als eine kritik an der
medienkritik das bedeutet digitalität
ist mehr als die summe der neuen medien
digitalität ist kein technologisches
phänomen zumindest nicht primär dass ein
kulturelles phänomen
um die kultur der digitalität zu
verstehen müssen wir die ethischen
epidemiologischen konto logischen grund
planen der digitalität kläre der
schlüsselbegriff das ist meine
hauptthese dieser vorleser für eine
philosophie der digitalität liste
begriff der virtuellen realität den wir
allerdings ganz scharf unterschreiben
müssen von ähnlichen phänomenen
zumindest der wortbedeutung nach der
simulation von der illusion von der
fiktion die müssen wir davon
unterscheiden sonst werden wir zur meine
these der digitalität philosophisch als
phänomen nicht gerecht bin ich zunächst
einmal auf künstliche intelligenz und
objektivität eingegangen auch hier
wieder im sinne der lebenswelt also
künstliche intelligenz nicht als eine
abstrakte gefahr bekommen noch auf die
these des tanz humanismus nicht
spekulativ ist und etwas ganz konkretes
das ist mir ganz wichtig diese vorlesung
hervorzuheben dass digitalität immer
bezug zur lebenswelt hat das digitale
technik im idealfall nahtlos sich
integriert und verschmilzt und seine
lebensweltlichen alltag dass es
vielleicht sogar zu einer lebensform
wird auch der begriff der menschen
erschienen interaktion scheint mir für
künstlich intelligente diesem lebens
wirklich im sinne der digitalität nicht
mehr adäquat zu sein warum weil immer
mehr teil dieser lebenswelt wird wir
sollten deswegen kann nicht im sinne
eines subjekts oder objekts verstehen
sondern eher auf den prozess der
mustererkennung
fokussieren im sinne einer intelligenzen
leistung vielleicht sogar auf eines
vermögens und dies intelligenz leistung
lässt sich hier um zu leben zu
integrieren und mit anderen menschen in
operation vernetzt also auch hier wieder
eine erweiterung unserer vermögen und
diese erweiterung heißt eben gerade eine
lebensweltliche perspektive auf kann zu
werfen
ich hatte schon daraufhin geworfen
hingewiesen kns künstliche neuronale zu
operieren auf gewaltigen datenmengen in
welch immer menschliche leistung
eingehen also künstliche intelligenz ist
nichts abstraktes was unabhängig von uns
agiert kein unabhängiges objektives
ist was lebensweltlich ist frei
neuronale netze eine datenbasis brauchen
woher bekommen sie die datenbasis zu uns
das heißt menschliche leistung leistung
interferieren sie sind nicht unabhängig
voneinander sind sie stehen eine
wechselwirkung
keine ins lernen durch versuchen wird um
sie korrigieren sich selbst sie erlangen
wissen so könnte man sagen durch
anpassung ihre gewichtung sie müssen
jedoch immer und das ist ganz
entscheidend ein ziel von außen
vorgesetzt bekommen das heißt sie sind
niemals ab autonom dass die
eigenständige entscheidung treffen sind
sie sind nur hypothetisch auch nur unter
der bedingung dass sie ein ziel
verbundes wieder lebenswelt nicht
vorgesetzt bekommen
das heißt wir sollten nicht so sehr
subjekt objekt theoretisch auf karriere
frittieren zahnoperation theoretisch
oder lebenswelten wenn wir das tun dann
können wir künstliche intelligenz nicht
nur als eine simulation oder duplikation
und intelligenz verstehen sein als
virtuelle realität und mein vorschlag
ist hier trifft der inter objektivität
dafür einzuführen das heißt es geht um
eine vernetzung einen dazwischen inter
eine interferenz zwischen verschiedenen
zielen und um unsere ziele zu
realisieren können wir eine erweiterung
im sinne der christen intelligenz
anstrebt das heißt eine verbindung in
der objektivität bedeutet einen kontext
von gründen und zielen der durch künsten
intelligenz weiter vernetzt und
verstärkt natürlich immer auch im
verbund mit dem internet
es ist noch ganz wichtig zu betonen dass
es sich bei künstlicher intelligenz
nicht um etwas starkes schematisches
handelt was jetzt der begriff des
algorithmus nahelegen könnte häufig wird
künstliche intelligenz reduziert auf
künstliche neuronale netze und dann auf
algorithmen und dann ist das argument so
ein algorithmus sagt ganz klar was zu
tun ist sowie ein rezept und dann
rattert das ganze durch es ist schon
richtig nur hat es haben es auch
algorithmen von künstlichen neuronalen
netzen immer mit einer empirischen
datenbasis zu tun diese datenbasis die
liefern wir das heißt wir haben es
gewissermaßen mit anschauung zu tun
konkret und anschauungsmaterial das ist
die datenbasis die empirisch ist und es
gibt ein begriff der begriff ist der
algorithmus sie denken jetzt bestimmt an
kant und ich glaube so kann man es auch
sehen die erkenntnis die durch
künstliche neuronale netze erzeugt wird
ist so was wie eine synthese von
anschauung und begriff diese kann tische
zweistimmigkeit lehrer so kann man das
glaube ich ziemlich gut
erklären und wir sollten so meine ich
auch immer auf die muster 8 und die es
der künstliche intelligenz geht und die
muster sind lebensweltlich das heißt
kürzlich in der netze haben das
wesentliche mit mustererkennung zu tun
musste erkennung hat eine formale
algorithmische und auch einem material
tierisch zeit ich hatte auf die
datenbasis hingewiesen muster lassen sie
auf ganz verschiedene weisen verstehen
und strukturieren unsere lebenswelt in
ganz verschiedenen bereichen zum
beispiel in der wirtschaft
wachstumsmuster wachstums konstellation
in der ethik verhaltensmuster wenn auch
nicht subjektive motivation künstlich in
der wahl alle netze werden wir nicht auf
uns subjektivität unmittelbar anwenden
können das glaube ich nicht auf qualia
lässt sie sich nicht anwenden aber doch
auf uns zu äußeren verhaltensmuster und
auch da wann kann man eine ethik
entwickeln dann ist die ästhetik ein
bereich von möglichen mustern zb
komposition musste ich verweise schon
auf beethoven ex auf die zehnte sind von
mir auf die wir auch noch genauer
eingehen das geht und komposition muster
dann kann die künstliche intelligenz als
muse verwendet werden auch gewisse
muster schon vor zu prägen und auch
emotionen lassen sich als muster
verstehen nämlich im sinne der
akustischen musste so wie meine stimme
melodie ist das auch ein muster mit
mittels dessen ich auf emotion
rückschließen kann natürlich gibt es
auch visuelle musste mein
gesichtsausdruck usw da kann man auch
ganz viele andere musste sich überlegen
musste also leitfähigkeit der haut lässt
rückschlüsse zu auf gewisse emotion eine
hirnorganische vorgänge lassen sich als
muster verstehen die auf emotionen hin
interpretiert werden können dann die
medizin auch krankheits muster können
wir mittels ki erkennen visuell durch
bildgebungsverfahren akustisch
sicherlich auch olfaktorisch usw sondern
sie ganz viele musste bereiche denken
und natürlich auch die sprache
sprachmuster ich hatte an die pelle
hingewiesen es gibt visuelle muster also
die gedruckte schrift und auch
akustische musste also hörverstehen
spracherkennung und so weiter das heißt
ki ist mehr nur als ein instrument soll
wird immer mehr teil unserer lebenswelt
im sinne einer erweiterung unseres
denkens vielleicht sogar auch unseres
fühlen sich hatte hier schon auf emotion
bezogen so verstanden hat
nichts mit die transform an ismus zu tun
es ist viel banaler es ist viel lebens
wirklich wir brauchen keine
apokalyptischen spekulation und
zukunftsszenarien das ist alles schon
lebens wirklich da und wird sicherlich
immer mehr teil unserer lebenswelt
werden aber ganz unmerklich
unspektakulär
dann zur biologie des internets das
internet hatte ich im anschluss an
luciano florida argumentiert ist ein
paradigma von technologien dritte ort
weise ist eine technologie die sich
wieder auf technologie bezieht eine
höhere stufe
technologie die nicht unmittelbar mit
der natur natürlichen welt in eine
verbindung steht der technologische
aspekte wie auch bei künstlicher
intelligenz tritt im internet immer
weiter zurück das internet so meine
these sie werden sich erinnern ist nicht
so sehr eine technologie oder ein medium
sondern ein virtueller handlungsraum und
heute werde ich auf das metaversum
ausblicken doch zu sprechen kommen was
eine konsequente fortführung dieses
gedankens des internets als eines
handlungsraum assist da hatte ich den
begriff der trans subjektivität kurz
eingeführt das ist komplementär zum
begriff der inter objektivität es
bedeutet so viel das bia mentale
subjektive gehalten als ideen gedanken
meinungen gefühl dass wir die
enttäuschung kann also über die unsere
subjektiven grenzen hinaus teilen können
also von uns lösen und in das internet
als ein kontext einbeziehen können da
ist natürlich die funktion des teilens
besonders wichtig dann habe ich noch den
begriff der transzendenten tendenz
geprägt vom internet zum intranet oder
andersrum besser gesagt vom internet zum
internet das heißt das internet ist
immer etwas begrenzt das grenzland was
ich abkapselt und das internet ist
dieser tendenz entgegen gesetzt das
internet tendiert nicht zu abkapselung
so scheint mir wir müssen darüber dann
auch genauer diskutieren wenn es um das
dort nicht geht sei prinzipiell scheint
im internet die tendenz gehe zu wohnen
alle möglichen separaten bereichen
miteinander in verbindung zu setzen das
war auch die these dieses buches
digitale aufklärung wo argumentiert
wurde dass durch die digitalisierung
alles schneller und alles vernetzter
auch wichtig ist in diesem zusammenhang
der app ist theologie des internets dass
das internet eine besondere logik
aufweist die mit dem suchen nach
informationen zu tun hat wir hatten in
der letzten sitzung anschluss darüber
diskutiert wie viele informationen
überhaupt durch das internet beziehen
können das wissen wird ist nicht sehr
groß und man schätzt dass da wurde
dankenswerterweise auch noch mal darauf
hingewiesen sondern nur sehr wenige
daten die im internet wirklich
handhabbar auffindbar vor und selbst die
find barren erfüllbaren daten mittels
suchmaschinen müssen eben ganz geschickt
angestellt werden es gibt keine gelben
seiten wie eine autorin auch mal
argumentiert hat sondern da müssen wir
ganz geschickt eine systemische zugangs
weiß etablieren und das führt auch zu
weiteren fragen nämlich nach der piste
nischenexistenz im internet ich werde
gefunden also bin ich könnte man sagen
wenn ich nicht im internet gefunden
werde durchsucht bots zu algorithmen zu
anfragen suchbegriffe bin ich dann
überhaupt noch als aushilfe mit dem
suchen zusammen dann besteht natürlich
eine intelligenz ihre künstliche jetzt
im internet die gewissermaßen
blasenbildung befördert wir sehen dass
zum beispiel bei youtube wenn wir
automatisch suchvorschläge bekommen
automatische fortsetzung des videos
schauen uns irgendwelche videos von
einer dokumentation über ein thema an
und bekommen dann ganz ähnliche team
automatisch generiert vorgeschlagen das
hat die gefahr dass wir in einer blase
bleiben und fehlende
entgegengesetzt informationen gar nicht
mehr vorgeschlagen bekommen aufgrund
dieser informationsflut die wir
irgendwie handhabbar machen müssen
natürlich kann man sich jetzt überlegen
ob man nicht auch zu programmieren
könnte die gerade dieser tendenz
entgegenwirken hier steht natürlich mit
ökonomisches interesse auch raum dann
brauchen wir so scheint es mir eine
spezifische hermeneutik des internets
das heißt eine theorie des verstehens
weil das internet nicht unmittelbar
seine information teils gibt wir
brauchen eine frage und such logik die
uns das internet mit seinen ganzen
informationen verstehen lässt
idealfall ist das internet ein
repräsentatives netz das heißt es zeigt
es verschweigt nichts es lässt uns
partizipieren so ist es natürlich noch
lange nicht hier kann man ein ideal
begriff des internets konstruieren und
das habe ich auch teilweise gemacht aus
philosophischer sicht der natürlich noch
weit entfernt von der gegenwärtigen
realität ist
wichtig ist mir aber noch einmal zu
betonen dass das internet nicht nur zu
einem grundbedürfnis geworden ist schon
immer mehr als ein mögliches grundrecht
ins zentrum rückt wir haben darüber
diskutiert wie sich so ein recht
durchsetzen diese spannende frage ich
darf aber darauf hinweisen dass auch
wasserzugang als grundrecht angesehen
wird und lang nicht alle menschen auf
dieser welt haben zugang zu fließen
fassen ja ja und auch hier würde man es
gerne durchsetzen stößt aber immer
wieder an grenzen das heißt aber in
meinen augen nicht dass nicht doch sich
überlegen kann als solches grundrecht zu
formulieren genauso natürlich grundrecht
auf bildung und so weiter meine these
war dass das internet ein besonderes
grundrecht ist weil es durch seine
vernetzende struktur andere grundrechte
erst ermöglicht wenn ich internetzugang
haben habe ich zugleich zugang zu
medizinischen wissen das heißt ich habe
medizinische vorsorge damit zumindest
keine direkte heilung jetzt aber
vielleicht gibt es anregungen dazu ich
habe zugang zu bildung das heißt das
bildungsrecht recht auf bildung wissen
habe ich damit auch abgedeckt das zeigt
schon dass das internet mich auf
derselben ebene ist wie andere
grundbedürfnisse ist sondern irgendwie
ihn über gelder übergeordneten seine art
meta grundbedürfnis wie mehr statt dann
kann man sich die frage stellen ob wir
eine demokratische internet regierung
benötigen das internet wesentlich einer
anarchistischen strukturiertes oder
kommerziell das wird man auch noch heute
am ende noch mal kurz behandeln wenn es
um die politik der digitalität geht und
dann scheint doch auch wieder stichwort
lebenswelt lebens von das internet zu
einer lebensform zu werden luciano
florida hat hier den begriff des onlive
geprägt
ja dann war ein ganz großes wichtiges
thema ich habe schon darauf hingewiesen
das thema virtuelle realität hier gibt
es ganz verschiedene
assoziationen eine nicht repräsentative
umfrage die ich ihnen hier auch nochmal
wiedergebe simulation wird hier häufig
genannt künstlichkeit
fähig als auch schein
digitalisierung wird auch damit in
verbindung gebracht nicht echte realität
ja was ist dann die echte realität
was ist also virtuelle realität
es hat eine komplexe begriffsgeschichte
es gibt eine neuere begriffs verwendung
die virtualität im sinne der optische
illusion behandelt und eine ältere
tradition das geht auf aristoteles
zurück die virtualität im sinne kraft
verstehen virtuos lateinisch kraft
tugend und
ich glaube dass wir um das internet und
andere phänomene der digitalität adäquat
als
lebensweltlich bedeutsam zu verstehen
wir zurück müssen zum zweiten
krebs sichtlichen bedeutungs spektrum
nämlich virtualität als kraft
aufkommen der neuen medien gewinnen
dieser zweite sind immer mehr an
bedeutung die virtuelle realität wird
immer mehr als eine realität eigenen
rechts sichtbar die von der bloßen
simulation und illusion verschieden ist
das ist nicht nur spielerei wasser
betreiben wenn wir im internet sind das
ist wirklich bedeutsam das hat auch
konsequenz durchaus auch im negativen
sinne also nicht nur spielerei ja dann
können wir jetzt die neuen medien im
sinne der virtuellen realität bestimmen
das virtuelle realität wird immer mehr
als ein modus von realität und gerade
nicht mehr als eine art von
realitätsverweigerung oder
realitätsflucht sichtbar das sieht man
ja häufig wenn man diese wie auch
brillen sieht sicherlich hat es damit
etwas auf sich was nicht direkt realität
ist deswegen argumentiere ich dafür dass
diese wie auch brille nicht der
inbegriff von virtueller realität ist
wie ich sie versteht es handelt sich
hierbei immer noch um simulation aber
bedeutsam wird einfach die auffassung
dass virtuelle realität mehr teil
unserer lebenswelt teil der realität
werden und gerade nicht mehr nur
fluchtmöglichkeiten sind sondern alter
tiefe realisierungs weisen ermöglichen
also sprich unsere kreativität
letztendlich stärken an sie appellieren
ich hatte schon darauf hingewiesen
virtualisierung müssen wir als
alternative realisierung verstehen und
hier gebe ich jetzt ein paar beispiele
die wir anhand der geschichte der
menschheit sehen können wir haben
begonnen mit naturalien als ökonomischen
größen naturalien wurden häufig dann
umgesetzt umsetzbar gemacht sprich
anders realisiert alternativ realisiert
im sinne des wertes der wert ließ sich
anders realisieren durch münster
münzgeld durch banknoten und banknoten
durch online wer online guthaben
sie sehen wir lösen uns immer mehr von
der physischen seite
naturalien sind viel vergänglicher als
es nur ums geld wenn ein apfel wird ein
paar tagen unter schlechten bedingungen
unbrauchbar bei münzgeld ist es so nicht
banknoten hingegen schon der geldschein
ich so gut gelagert wird bei
online-werbung oder kann wieder sagen
wenn der computer und sofort abgesehen
es wird unabhängig von der physischen
seit das ganze wird virtualisiert
genauso kann man ein physisches
universität seminar wie es in der korona
phase erlebt habe als ein virtuelles
digitales seminare veranstalten und hier
sehen wir plötzlich ganz neue
möglichkeiten der didaktischen
realisierbarkeit nämlich teilen von
dokumenten interaktion wird viel
unmittelbarer möglich wir können andere
medien unmittelbar einbeziehen was wir
so einen physischen universitäts seminar
reibungslos nicht tun können wir müssen
immer schritte zurücklegen wir haben
vielmehr die mechanische seite im spiel
und diese reibungslos ich kite mit blick
auf raum und zeit ist doch eine andere
im virtuellen raum ich komme noch einmal
heute auf raum und zeit der digitalität
zu sprechen wir können physische
büchereien haben wo die bücher mit der
zeit abgegriffen werden ab genutzt
werden da fließt meinen kaffee drüber
[Musik]
und wir stellen mein buch in der falsche
falschen bereich rein wir haben eine
virtuelle bücherei wo wir sofort nach
dem buch suchen können das fühlt sich
das digitale exemplar wird nicht
schlechter je häufiger es durch
virtuelle hände geht die häufiger ist
gelesen wird es bleibt identisch wir
sehen also hier findet einiges statt was
ich verändern ich habe die frage
aufgeworfen ob wikipedia eine
virtualisierung eines herkömmlichen
brockhaus es ist das möchte ich ein
fragezeichen versehen ist nämlich nicht
direkt derselbe wir sehen hier ändert
sich einiges auch was die autorschaft
anbelangt auch glaube ich dass youtube
eine form der virtualisierung des
fernsehens ist aber das muss man
natürlich noch genauer beschreiben darum
geht es mir auch wenn ich weil es
prinzipiell kein
medienwissenschaftliche seminar ist das
heißt wie gesagt es geht weniger um die
technische seite also lebensverhältnisse
entscheidung seite und die
unterscheidung zwischen sender und
empfänger die häufig bei medien sehen
die dritt immer mehr zurück
wir rezipieren nicht mehr nur die medien
im rahmen der digitalität sein wir
werden selbst aktiv das sehen wir dann
auch noch später am beispiel der
computerspiele die auch nicht in
analogie mit einem kino film oder einem
buch zu verstehen sind weil wir hier
selbst aktiv werden
genau also das war so die these
ich werde jetzt nicht genau noch auf die
modalität der virtuellen realität
eingehen es finden sie alles dann in den
jeweiligen sitzung noch genauer
behandelt ich möchte nur darauf
hinweisen dass wir den begriff der
virtuellen realität abgrenzen müssen mit
blick auf den begriff der möglichkeit
der wirklichkeit die fiktion der
simulation und der illustren und dass
wir eben diese begriffe erklären müssen
bevor wir uns daran machen können daran
begeben können eine ethik der
digitalität zu entwickeln die muss immer
schon diese begriffe klären sonst kann
sie nicht auf einem sicheren von der
mensch stattfinden
digitalität so meine thesen das
paradigma für virtuelle realität auch
wenn die virtuelle realität in anderen
bereichen bereits gesehen haben das
beispiel ist das geld was ich immer mehr
von der physischen seite löst ja ich
hatte das schon gebracht naturalien
wertes online guthaben
möchte hier auch nicht weiter darauf
eingehen
das kann man noch mal alles genauer
sehen also hier finden wir verschiedene
materielle basen für die virtuelle
realität des geldes muscheln papier
plastik hier sehen wir beim plastik wenn
man zum beispiel eine geldkarte haben
das natürlich die geldkarte selbst nicht
den wert
der auf ihr ist auf manchen geldkarten
befindet sich ein betrag von 50 euro auf
manchen einer form unter das heißt diese
plastikkarte kann nicht den wert
verbürgen es wäre ein widerspruch nach
das heißt auf dieser plastikkarten
agiert erst der wird mittels der
digitalen technologie
jetzt möchte ich noch auf den raum der
digitalität kurz eingehen der natürlich
auch ganz statt mit der
ontologie zusammenhängt ich hatte schon
erwähnt es geht um eine super
leitfähigkeit und um einen reibungslosen
kalten sich der digitalen technik
verdankt im virtuellen raum
stehen dinge viel engeren beziehungen
können sie viel leichter vernetzen weil
einfach distanzen wie sie im physischen
raum existiert keine rolle mehr für
digitale objekte darstellen alles mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit unterwegs die
räumlichkeit kommt eine ganz andere
prägung genauso auch mit der zeit auch
die zeit logan ist in der digitalen
realität etwas anderes weil es hier
nicht so sehr und die sukzession geht
sondern ihr und die vernetze also eine
andere zeit logik die der virtuellen
realität der digitalität zugrunde liegt
hier habe ich mich auf die zeit von john
meckert bezogen und dafür argumentiert
dass die zeit der digitalität keine
chronologische ist eine logische zeit
ist ich bringe noch mal diese reihen sie
sehen also hier die a3 das ist die immer
von mir als subjekt abhängt dh es gibt
einen jetzt punkt und es gibt ein
zukünftiges ein vergangenes ereignis das
ist dann gibt es die drei da spielt das
noch nicht und schon keine rolle da
liegen alle ereignisse geordnet vor
natürlich in zeitlicher reihenfolge also
immer vor mm wafern aber es geht hier
nicht um ein jetzt
oder einer kommendes ereignis alles ist
schon da in seiner zeitlichen ordnung
oder gibt sie zählen hier sehen sie hier
fehlt derzeit weil hier sehen sie eben
es ist keine zeitliche ordnung mehr
seine andere ordnung wie genau die
ordnung zu verstehen ist muss man sich
fragen mit geht es darum dass ich eben
glaube dass die cdu ihr die zeitliche
oder logische ordnung der digitalen
phänomene bestimmt dann bin ich noch
kurz auf den begriff des raumes eine
chronologie der digitalität als auch
hier es wird abstrahiert in der
digitalität von der lokalisation also
das wo spielt immer weniger eine rolle
als tritt anstelle des
subsystem der lokalisation tritt die
bedeutung der relation ein physisches
lexikon habe ich irgendwo in meinem
regal im keller oder auf dem dachboden
war immer wikipedia wo habe ich die wo
ist die auf meinem pc klar aber
irgendwie auch auf allen anderen pcs
immer cloud im server aber auch die
clouds und die server sind miteinander
vernetzt als ist lässt sich gar nicht
mehr so klar bestimmen sicherlich mag es
ein master server geben wo die meisten
daten drauf sind aber permanent wird ja
werden wir neue informationen darauf
gespeichert die von anderen nutzerinnen
nutzer kommt also das ganze ist nicht
mehr so eindeutig raum zeitlich zu
fordern hat das macht das ganze raum
zeitliche differenz
ja wikipedia steht nicht im regal und
veraltet nicht nach 30 jahren weil es
permanent aktualisiert ist ein sich
selbst aktualisierenden
lexikon könnte man sagen neben inter
subjektiv organisiert und im virtuellen
digitalen raum wird zeitlosen metadaten
dass nicht die substanz eines
dienstbetrieb dann ab für derrick
schlechten der zeit da fließt die zeit
fast schon in seiner substanz mit ein
bei wikipedia artikeln ist es einen
millimeter information die ich zwar
erkennen kann die aber für den inhalt
direkt keine auswirkung hat
genau also der physische rahmen wird im
digitalen virtuellen raum ihr zu einer
komplexen orientierungs relation das
wäre hier mein argument ja dann immer
auf die ethik der digitalität
eingegangen hier hatte ich das internet
als einen handlungsraum bestimmt einen
virtuellen handlungsraum wir müssen also
virtuelle realität stärker als die
simulation verstehen sonst können wir
das internet nicht als einen
handlungsrahmen sind sonst werde das
internet nicht bloße spielerei
ein bloßer schein da gibt's natürlich
auch thesen die dafür argumentieren das
wäre in meinen augen aber nicht adäquat
angesichts der lebensweltlichen realität
des internets und wir müssen natürlich
auch sexuelle handlungen bestimmen und
dazu spielt wieder raumzeit der
virtuellen realität eine große geduld es
gebe ich noch ein paar beispiele für
virtuelle handlungsräume soziale
plattformen und kanäle wie facebook
twitter youtube
jetzt ändert sich was facebook heißt es
bei facebook seien meter das metaversum
gibt ja einige gamer fiction elemente
also hier tut sich gerade einiges meter
würde sich bestimmt nicht mehr primär
als soziale plattform verstehen wollen
glaube ich nicht dass wir noch mehr das
metaversum mehr sein als nur eine
soziale plattform ist will eine
virtuelle handlungsraum sein soziale
plattformen sind aber schon als solche
keine bloßen medien die wir rezipieren
sondern fängt schon an sie sind
handlungsräume indem wir virtuell
agieren
wenn das wind internet ein virtueller
handlungsraum ist dann muss auch sein
institut uhr geschützt und gepflegt
werden ich bin darauf eingegangen dass
es ein internet tresor so eine art gibt
das dem verkehrsministerium
unter steht also wo straßen geteerte
straßen analog betrachtet werden zu zum
internet da muss man sich fragen ob das
adäquat ist aber jedenfalls muss muss
auch die internet-infrastruktur gepflegt
werden damit wir darin gut handeln
können damit wir keine hindernisse in
den weg setz bekommen dass wir
barrierefreiheit genießt
handlungsfreiheit im virtuellen raum
genießen können ganz wichtig also was
ist jetzt eine virtuelle handlung muss
man sich fragen handlungen sind mehr als
bloße ereignis in der welt man muss
erstmal überhaupt beim physischen
handlungs begriff anfangen handlung sind
gezeichnet durch internationalität also
gerichtet des geistes absichten ziele
pläne das gehört dazu
du deine davidson hat das gesagt also
intentionalen gerichtet ist ganz wichtig
absichten rationalität wir müssen immer
gründe geben rechtfertigen geben dann
müssen auf die frage warum eine antwort
haben ja das ist das auch keine
wirkliche handlung
kontrolle wir können nicht einfach nur
unkoordiniert da versuchen unsere
intensität zu realisieren unsere ziele
sondern müssen unseren körper auch
richtig einsetzen dafür müssen uns
bewegen und es braucht natürlich auch
eine kausalität eine kraftanstrengung zu
verwirklichen wir müssen unseren körper
bei der physischen handlung im raum und
zeit orientieren jetzt sieht das
natürlich ganz anders aus eine virtuelle
handlung wenn raum und zeit sich anders
verhalten da passt also wie
unterscheidet sich eine virtuelle von
einer physischen handlungen können uns
fragen ja virtuelle handlung so finde
ich sollte man argumentieren sind mehr
als nur mausklicks na das wäre eine
reduktionistischen auffassung virtuelle
handlung sind jedoch tendenziell and
körper nicht bauen zeit gehen als
aspekte nicht in die virtuelle handlung
ein nur als mieter garten das heißt sind
äußerlich virtuellen virtuelle handlung
bestehen im herstellen von beziehungen
mögliche beziehungen sind zum beispiel
italien vernetzen im raum des internets
und virtuelle handlung sind aufgrund
ihrer raumzeit problematisch endlich
durch der identifizierung des
verantwortlichen virtuellen zu kurz das
wird für das objekt ist nicht mehr so
einfach dingfest zu machen in raum und
zeit
das ist jetzt eine virtuelle handlung
ich habe jetzt eher auf das subjekt auch
ein bisschen konzentriert also nach
welchen kriterien können wir jetzt wird
die handlung ethischen normativ
bewährten erweiterte die virtuelle
handlung den handlungsraum das heißt
verknüpft sie informationen sinnvoll im
internet müssen wir uns fragen beispiele
sind mitarbeitern wikipedia mitarbeitern
fallen netzinfrastruktur freeware
rezeption und bewertung von horizont
erweitern informationen programm auch in
kommerzialisierung ein großes thema die
wirtschaft willkommen bei metaversum lob
auszusprechen
ich glaube dass es gut für eine handlung
als informativen sinne eine ethisch gute
virtuelle handlungs eine geben zur
erweiterung des handlungsspielraums
antritt und die kommerzialisierung trägt
nur bedingt zur erweiterung bei ich bin
hier sehr kritisch meine persönliche
auffassung deswegen mal scheint mir dass
die entkam materialisierung ihr der
bessere weg ist um den handlungsraum zu
erweitern beschränkt die virtuelle
handlung den handlungsraum entkoppelt
sie sich davon oder vernichtet sie ihn
gar stichwort eignet
fake news identitäts spiegel und wie ich
meine auch kommerzialisierung erscheint
mir auch im internet als handlungsraum
entgegenzustehen weil es bestimmte
menschen ausschließt die eben nicht die
finanziellen möglichkeit haben an dieser
information an der infrastruktur zu
partizipieren
was ist dann ein virtuelles objekt
müssen wir uns fragen wie unterscheidet
sich ein physisches von einem virtuellen
subjekt ein virtuelles objekt
interagiert körperlos auch wenn es durch
einen lebendigen körper funk fundiert
ist wir sollten also nicht denken dass
sie irgendwie unsere
existenz im sinne einer bloßen software
zu verstehen ist das gibt es diese
auffassung wir kommen noch auf die
kurzwahl zu sprechen wenn es um den
trans mannis muss geht ich glaube dass
wir immer akzeptieren sollten dass
hinter den virtuellen subjekten man kann
darüber diskutieren ob bot auch
virtuelles objekte sind jedenfalls dass
bei den meisten virtuellen subjekten im
starken sind die auch virtuelle handlung
frei verziehen dass da einfach lebendige
menschen dahinter stehen bin die person
dennoch sind sie nicht einfach darauf zu
reduzieren und sagt es gibt eine eigene
logik die die virtuellen subjekte
auszeichnet das kann man zu jedem fragen
ist künstliche intelligenz ein subjekt
und akteur ich würde dafür argumentieren
weder das eine noch das andere sei neben
inter objektivität ist hier das
stichwort das virtuelle zu klick kann in
namentlicher anonymer und pseudonyme
form existieren dass es auch noch
spannend das kann natürlich auch ein
körperliches zu blicken aber es ist
wesentlich schwerer zu greifen ein
virtuelles objekt aufgrund der raum und
zeit logik des internets ein virtuelles
objekt problematische identitäts
bedingung das ist deswegen vor allem
definiert durch seine internationalität
das heißt seine suchanfrage seine
vernetzung und teilung von informationen
die wahl seiner avatare pseudonyme in
der kriminalistik versucht man häufig
auch virtuelles objekt zu identifizieren
also rückzuführen auf körperliche
subjekt im papier geht man dann häufig
von den zug und fragen aus und kann so
sehr gut die individualität
rekonstruieren
ja zur geschichte des internets
was hat es damit auf sich möchte ich
auch nicht verschweigen
1990 die aus dem apparat hervor das ist
ein akronym advanced research projects
agency network also das netzwerk war
hier ganz wichtig da sieht man es war
eine kooperation durchaus auch
wissenschaftlich des m ai aber zugleich
auch
verteidigungsministerium ziel war eine
topologie also eine raum logik des
dezentralen netzwerk sie nicht an
einzelnen rechnen sondern es war das da
zwischen den rechnern was entscheiden
wurde und seit 1989 beginnt immer mehr
die kommerzialisierung des world wide
webs tim berners lee ist natürlich noch
zu erwähnen das cern genf die idee des
hypertext es mit p natürlich die quelle
ist wikipedia hier noch mal eine
veranstaltung der struktur des internets
wir haben selbst mal drüber diskutiert
das klärwerk macht nur einen geringen
teil aus dass daten bezeichnet also
diese gesamte unteren bereich hier da
kommt man nur mit einem tor browser rein
und das ist das obere was durch
suchmaschinen gefunden wird und das ist
eben nicht der größte teil und das
stellt natürlich die frage wie wir zur
information kommen die besuchen und das
stellt die frage wird die frage nach der
hermeneutik das internet auf quelle ist
personals dann habe ich hier ganz
empirisch mal statistisch quelles
statista.com
mal das nutzerverhalten hier ihnen
dargestellt war es noch ziemlich trivial
ist möchte ich sagen senden empfang von
e-mails ist das eine wirkliche handlung
und gut suchen nach informationen bei
waren und dienstleistungen das ist ja
auch etwas
kommerzielles
konsumorientiert ist also man sieht hier
eigentlich wirkliche virtuelle
handlungen werden noch nicht so sehr
voll zu im strengen sinne wie ich sie
jetzt stimmt hat telefonieren
videotelefonie vielleicht ja hier fehlt
zb auch noch computerspielen ist hier
nicht aufgezeichnet und auch zum
beispiel bildungs bildungs rezeption als
zb universität seminare auch schulische
fortbildung auch das kommt hier nicht
direkt
rein statistisch ich glaube auch dass
computerspiele immer mehr zunehmen
werden also in ein paar jahren wird das
ganz anders aussehen
das heißt das internet wird noch
überwiegend instrumentell als ein
kommunikations informations und
unterhaltungsmedium benutzt seit der
kuba-krise wird es aber immer mehr als
eine interaktion zum arbeitsraum genutzt
etwa über videotelefonie und -konferenz
tust durch cloud technologien wird der
arbeitsplatz in den virtuellen raum
verlegt dass wir überall ausgearbeitet
werden kann ubiquitäre es computing
stichwort home office computerspiele
finden nicht mehr nur gegen den computer
statt sind gegen andere spielerinnen und
spieler auf der ganzen welt das kam mir
so ein bisschen zu kurz in dieser stadt
ist ja jetzt gibt es aktuelle forschungs
tendenzen das internet wird immer mehr
als ein eigener forschungsgegenstand
wahrgenommen jetzt wird zum gegenstand
interdisziplinärer forschung es wird
natürlich auch zum gegenstand
politischer debatten und zuständigkeiten
und deswegen wurde hier das oxford
internet institute gegründet weil es
eine wirkliche interdisziplinäre der
sammlung von verschiedenen forscherinnen
und forschern ist können sich mal
informieren in deutschland gibt es
verschiedene nachfolge
institutionen
habe ich auch in dieser entsprechenden
vorlesung genau dargestellt anhand von
beispielen dass hier noch kurz zur
ediger künstlich telegent müssen hier
also die frage beantworten ist
künstliche intelligenz ein subjekt kann
künstliche intelligenz handeln besitzt
künstliche intelligenz internationalität
ist künstliche intelligenz auto herum
dass sie die fragen ich habe einige
davon schon
beantwortet sollen wir als technik
technologie verstehen kann hier als
werkzeug instrument können die
intelligenz als medium als objekt oder
maschine manche sprechen auch von
intelligent machines karl subjekt kann
er als prozess oder karriere als
struktur ist sind diese letzteren beiden
am sympathischsten
virtuelle realität werde auch noch ein
kanditat das heißt es gibt jetzt
verschiedene in meinen augen
problematische position bezüglich kann
nie von denen ich mich abgrenzen wollte
in dieser vorlesung von der
ideologisierung von k im rahmen einer
trans minister theologischen silicon
valley ideologie hatten julian
nida-rümelin bild geprägten begriff dann
der andere profi sierung von cali als
reporter als ki sollte nicht im sinne
analogie zu menschen verstehen obwohl
natürlich ki ursprünglich kann zumindest
sie künstliche neuronale netze an
unserem hirn aller logisch ausgerichtet
sind aber das ist ja was anderes als
dann von einer person zu sprechen auch
die banalisierung ist glaube ich ein
punkt an dem wir uns vornehmen uns
unterscheiden müssen also karriere ist
mehr als ein bloßes hilfsmitteln ist
nicht ein hammer der öko hängt also dem
ich hingehe und in der nutzer sein wird
immer mehr teil der lebenswelt dann auch
die traumatisierung im sinne von manfred
spitzer einstellung zur digitalisierung
so kann man natürlich auch argumentieren
dass die kg eine gefahr der moderne ist
das scheint mir aber auch eine
ideologische gegen position zu sein zum
punkt einzelne brauchen einen gesunden
philosophischen mittel winkel ja also
hier stellen sich dann auch ganz
konkrete ethische fragen der künstliche
intelligenz die verantwortungs zu
schreiben wird immer schwieriger wer
trägt denn jetzt die verantwortung wenn
zum beispiel ein tesla eine person über
fährt der hersteller der die nutzer die
zur datenbasis beitragen als das
fahrverhalten dieser vielen zutaten
basis beitragen den nutzer oder die ki
selbst
luciano flori die geht so weit selbst
der ki etwas zuzuschreiben ja ich bin
ein bisschen vorsichtig sein konkurrent
aktiv zu sein
wir sollten keinesfalls eine erweiterung
unseres virtuellen handlungsspielraums
verstehen dessen grund verantwortliche
konnten wir immer selbst sind also meine
argumentation war hier der hersteller
von kakao oder die nutzer aber nicht
keine selbst es verteilt sich die
verantwortung unsere virtuellen handlung
sind viel vernetzter als es unsere
physischen handel und sind deswegen ist
die frage nach der verantwortung
zuschreibung von cali ebenfalls komplexe
es gibt die menschen die die algorithmus
programmieren
da liegt auch eine verantwortung drin
aber es gibt natürlich auch die menschen
die zu datenbasis beitragen auch da
liegt eine verantwortung drin es findet
also auch am übergang von der
individuellen zur kollektiven person
statt es gibt auch kollektive personen
wie man eben auch unternehmen als solche
bezeichnen könnte ja einzelne person
entscheiden immer weniger als individuen
sind es geht immer um den verbund der
entscheidungen und dieser verbund wird
durch das internet weiter vergrößert
also eine ethik der digitalität müsse
neben digitalen rechten auch ein katalog
digitaler pflichten formulieren da kann
auch sagen wenn es um richtig geht geht
es um die politik digitalität das stimmt
und deswegen muss man sich auch die
frage stellen wie ich hat ethische
ansatz dafür am geeignetsten ist die
tugend edicto.de ontologie oder
konsequenz iris muss dann müssen wir uns
die frage nach spezifisch digital
tugenden stellen wenn wir hier tätig
reflektieren
medienkompetenz als eine digitale tugend
proklamiert ich bin hier skeptisch
medienkompetenz darf jedenfalls mein
auge nicht so verstanden werden als
anleitung wie lange wie am tag vor dem
computer sitzen das ist wieder nicht der
begriff der digitalität der wie ich
meinte schon schwache normatives weil er
die gelungene lebens wirkliche
integration der neuen medien beinhaltet
zu nehmen muss im sinne einer
lebenswerten digital truppen verstanden
werden was das genau heißt das heißt wir
müssen die digitaltechnik als virtuelle
realität gebrauchen um die welt zu
verändern und zwar im guten wie auch in
schlechten leider aber eben möglichst
gut aber diese dieser einsatz der
technik ist prinzipiell moralisch gut
oder moralisch problematisch zu bewerten
und letztendlich geht es um die frage
wie wir die digitale technik so
einsetzen können da sie zur erweiterung
der virtuellen realität beitragen also
dass sie unseren freiheits raum
vergrößern deswegen bedeutet die
digitale trugen den übergang von der
digitalisierung zur digitalität zu
vollziehen also wir bleiben gerade nicht
stehen nur bei der technik wir sind
nicht alle technik expertinnen und
experten
wir müssen wenn wir die technik haben
sie sinnvoll einsetzen und sicherlich
auch auf die herstellerinnen hersteller
hinwirken dass sie noch technisch
verbessert wird aber das entscheidende
muss die lebensmittel seien und der sich
diese technik zu gewähren hat das ist
das entscheidende
und insofern ist der begriff der
digitalität bereits normativ und
verweist so auf die tätig
dann hatte ich noch einen ausblick auf
das digitale gute böse gebracht was ist
jetzt das digital gute es ist dasjenige
fast in virtuellen handlungsraum
vergrößern das heißt was unsere
virtuelle freiheit statt wir sind als
beispiel zu den open access freeware
wieder nur kommerzielle globale
bildungsangebote barrierefreiheit grenz
und kultur beschreibende kooperation des
weiterspinnen am öffentlichen netz und
so weiter wir können uns in ganz kleinen
dingen einbringen und das digital gute
voranbringen digital gemüse wäre in
diesem sind das wenige was den
virtuellen handlungs von einschränkt und
unsere virtuelle freiheit beschränkt
durch zum beispiel
eröffnet uns weiter durch klose
kommerzialisierung durch fehlenden
datenschutz durch abkapselung zur
intranets und durch identitätsdiebstahl
schwächung der internet-infrastruktur
hecking pishing und so weiter also die
ganzen vertrauen struktur kann natürlich
auch extrem geschwächt dann sind wir auf
die ästhetik nachdem er die ewig
behandelt haben sogar auf die ästhetik
eingegangene digitalität und zwar anhand
von zwei phänomene nämlich nfc nun von
starken und der ästhetik der künstlichen
intelligenz wenn die digitalisierung ein
virtueller handlungsrahmen öffnet dann
eröffnet sich damit auch ein wird für
kunst das ist glaube ich ganz wichtig
und die virtuelle kunst es auch nicht
auf die technik der digitalisierung zu
reduzieren auf die software und die
hardware ohne an bedeutung zu verlieren
auch ein physisches nicht digitales
nicht virtuelles gemälde von picasso ist
mehr als nur farbe auf leinwand also zu
sagen dass ein nfc 9 und 11 sind und
insofern keine kunst wäre meine ich
genau bisher wie sozusagen die kasse
gemeldet ist nicht nur farbpigmente auf
leinwand auf irgendwelchen materialien
organischen material der organische
materialien mischungen immer noch in
holz frau mit holzrahmen mit dazu nehmen
das ist ein reduktionistischen zugang
der meines erachtens nicht diese sache
adäquat ist allerdings gehorcht
virtuelle kunst einer anderen raum und
zeit logik als physische kunst es
beginnt schon damit wo sie sich befindet
das lässt sich nicht mehr so leicht
sagen im louvre oder irgendwo auf einer
festplatte oder irgendwo im internet das
ist die frage hier ist ein beispiel von
nfp
christie's versteigerte 2021 dieses nft
everyday das sind 5000 kleine digitale
bilder dann für fast 70 millionen
us-dollar für das gebiet ja das ist also
virtuelle kunst hier ist noch ein
anderes beispiel wird der kunst diesmal
aber mit hilfe von künstlicher
intelligenz erzeugt das portrait of
mettmann dpa lni
2018 verkauft für
1500 us-dollar also gibt gigantischen
summen es würde mit diesem algorithmus
erstellt und dieser algorithmus der war
in sich differenziert durch einen
generator ein diskriminiert und ganz
wichtig ist hier die datenbasis
15.000 porträts aus dem zeitraum von 14
bis zum zwanzigsten jahrhundert wurden
in ein gefüttert das hier hat wieder der
mensch sein anteil gehabt die datenbasis
zu liefern das bedeutet der mensch ist
da nicht ganz draußen vor gewesen als
diese künstlich liegen dieses bild
erzeugt hat auch deswegen nicht weil der
algorithmus natürlich auch von
menschenhand sage ich jetzt schon fast
ein virtueller mensch land programmiert
wurde hier schließen immer inter
objektiv menschliche interessen
menschliche faktoren mit einer und
dieser generator erzeugte ein bild auf
dieser empirischen datenbasis und der
generator der die screen versucht dann
ein unterschied zu finden zwischen dem
neu erstellten bild und den 15.000
porträts und wenn er kein unterschied
mehr finden konnte dann entstand eben
dieses bild und dieses bild was ich ihm
gezeigt hat erstaunliche ähnlichkeiten
zur modernen kunst zum beispiel planbar
der hier ein ähnliches bild gemalt hat
auch an hier gibt es ein
verfremdungseffekte über die ästhetische
qualität dieser virtuelle kunst kann man
sich natürlich streiten es gibt
natürlich auch noch anwendungen auf die
tonkunst die zehnte sinfonie die eben
durch künstliche dance vervollständigt
wurde
anhand von 40 skizzen auch hier kann mir
das sagen es sind kompositionen muster
auf die die ki trainiert wurde
und hier hat man versucht eine
melodieführung zu etablieren und eine
orchestrierung zu erlangen das war sehr
kompliziert interessant ist hier dass
die wirklich wie der junge beethoven
auch trainiert wurde also man hat sogar
die ki ein bildungsgang durchlaufen
lassen so dass sie erst auf die musik
des 18 der 110 trainiert wurde als eine
art ideengeschichtliche muster
hintergrund wir für beethoven damals
existierte
ja ich brauche hier dieses tonbeispiele
nicht mehr zu geben also man kann sich
das im internet anhören über die
qualität kann man wirklich streiten ob
es wirklich genial ist was die calida
gemacht hat das ist jedenfalls
interessant sage ich mal solche
anwendungsbereiche auch zu sehen ja die
mensch maschine interaktion so kann man
zusammenfassend sagen die kann auch
unter ästhetischen gesichtspunkten
betrachtet werden ja nicht nur unter
ästhetischen gesichtspunkten
es handelt sich insofern und ästhetische
inter objektivität kunstschaffende und
künstliche intelligenz verhalten sich
nicht mehr subjekt objekt und subjekt
instrument für bilden sie einen inter
objektiven kreativen zusammenhang im
sinne virtueller kunstproduktion
künstliche intelligenz wird zu einer
virtuellen muss jetzt einer virtuellen
inspirationsquelle durch die
möglichkeiten der modifikation variation
und transformation bestehenden daten
nach was darauf kommt es wieder an das
auch immer einer grundlage die der
mensch der ki dem algorithmus zur
verfügung stellen das künstliche
intelligenz ist als solche nicht kreativ
sie hat also keine reflektierende
urteilskraft wie kann sagen würde aber
das lässt sich in kreative prozesse als
ein moment integrieren künstliche
intelligenz kann insofern überraschung
und neue perspektiven erzeugen die als
inspiration für unsere kunst schaffen
gehen können und jetzt möchte ich als
weiteres phänomen noch immer wiederholen
die ästhetik der computerspiele eigens
anführen die man besonders zusammen das
beispiel dafür zu sein scheinen also
welche philosophische bedeutung besitzen
spiele allgemein muss man sich zunächst
fragen welche philosophische bedeutung
besitzen computerspiele im besonderen
und dann auch noch die frage sind
computerspiele medien und wie verhalten
sich computer spiegelt sich simulation
illusion fiktion und virtuelle realität
simulieren computerspiele nur realität
wie verhalten sich nutzer und
computerspiele zueinander wie fernsehen
computerspiele teil einer kultur der
digitalität von der felix stalder
gesprochen hatte inwiefern sind
computerspiele gar teil einer lebensform
sehen wieder der bischof der lebensform
der wir hier sehr wichtig ist das heißt
wir müssen jetzt auf die anthropologie
des spiels eingehen und hier ist von
friedrich schiller ein wichtiges zitat
der mensch spielt nur wo er in voller
bedeutung des wortes mensch ist und er
ist nur da ganz mensch wo er spielt das
jetzt natürlich wieder voraus dass man
weiß was der mensch eigentlich ist
jedenfalls geht es hier um etwas
existenzielles etwas wesentliches auch
um etwas ganzes da ganz mensch was heißt
ganz mensch ganz manchester schüler
immer die vernunft und die natur
als unsere empirischen
unsere rationales all dies sind im spiel
vereint einer ganz engen einheit das
heißt es geht um die ganzheit des
menschen das ist für ihn deswegen ist so
wichtig weil er den menschen in seiner
ganzheit ästhetisch erziehen möchte
möchte die vernunft mit der empirie mit
den gefühlen den emotionen eine ganz
enge beziehung bringen beide auseinander
gestalt und nicht dass eine nur stärken
sieht man das häufig denkt bei der
erziehung der bildung dass nur die
vernunft trainiert werden muss nein es
geht ihm um die einheit lebendige einer
und ich glaube dass hier schon ein
fingerzeig gebe es auch für das
computerspiel aber nochmal ganz
allgemein zuvor im spiel entwirft sich
der mensch und seiner freiheit hier
experimentiert er mit möglichkeit und
wirklichkeit im spiel können wir immer
fiktional etwas tun den sie an die
siedler von catan dieses brettspiel auch
brettspiele sind natürlich spiele jetzt
kann man sich aber fragen stellen dann
computerspiele eine reform für ein spiel
darf wirklich mit brettspielen ich bin
der meinung ja aber darüber haben wir
auch treffen diskutiert besteht die
besonderheit von computerspielen im
gegensatz zu schaffen etwas was ihre
digitalität struktur aus macht es
natürlich auch das nutzt das spiel mit
go zusammen asiatischen raum prominent
sind computerspiele nur spiele oder sind
sie viel mehr als das was sind sie dann
genau das waren die fragen die wir uns
gestellt haben dann habe ich einen
kurzen durchlauf durch die evolution des
computerspiels gebracht beginnend mit
diesem spiel hier
von 172 in dieser version das sagen der
urvater wenn man so möchte man kann ein
bestimmter vorherige sachen finde aber
es ist schon ziemlich alt jetzt also
ziemlich genau 50 jahren ja spannend und
dann habe ich ein anderes beispiel von
der jüngsten evolution die anrede
entscheiden 5 die alle 50 jahre
praktisch nach punkt etabliert wurde
eine engine ist orange die software der
software motor der diese ganze grafik
ermöglicht
technologie eine spiele technologie und
hier ist besonders wichtig die der
schattenwurf an die lichtquellen
das ist also
ganz bezahlt für die neuere grad das ist
ein immer realistischer
ja dann hatte ich mich mit der ästhetik
digitalität noch weiter beschäftigen
eine vorlese und dafür argumentiert dass
computerspiele nicht mehr nur als
zeitvertreib angesehen werden lebenswelt
ich oder nutzlose spielerei das
natürlich auch aber eben nicht mehr nur
sondern dass sie immer mehr als
ästhetisch und philosophisch
interessante finden wenig ernst genommen
werden also mitten in der gesellschaft
angekommen ist und nicht mehr nur bei
nerds oder
pubertierenden jungs oder ich weiß nicht
was die spielereihe der computerspiele
die ist wirklich angekommen sie haben
auch so ihren und irgend ihren negativen
touch verloren scheint computerspiele
sind nicht nur spielereien und konsum
medien sind vielmehr experimentierfelder
auf den spielerischen verhältnis von
realität simulation fiktion und
illustriert werden hier ist noch ein
weiterer punkt der nation ist das
stichwort auch im bildungssektor also
spielelemente digitale spiele elemente
finden eingang in ganz verschiedene
lebenswege bereiche auch in die bildung
computerspiele sind so würde ich
argumentieren simulationen von fiktionen
also hier werden fiktionen nicht nur
rezitiert oder im agiert wie es ein buch
lesen eines romans der fall ist oder
nicht nur rezitiert wie im kino wenn ich
irgendwann fehlen mir anschaue jetzt sei
denn eine dokumentation habe sprechen
auf den filmen er sondern wir selbst
müssen diese fiktion selbst noch aktiv
umsetzen hier werden wir selbst aktiv
das heißt es ist eigentlich kein bloßes
konsum medium weil hier findet nicht nur
konsum stützen die bauaktivität
computerspiele sind bestandteil einer
kultur der digitalität weil in ihnen das
problem virtueller realität spielerisch
verhandeln sind im rahmen einer kultur
der digitalität können computerspiele zu
virtuellen realität werden so dass ihr
sie motive und fiktiver k aktuell in den
hintergrund rückt wenn es eben in diesen
spielen um objektive werte geht wenn wir
gegen andere menschliche gegner antreten
und westen im medium des computerspiels
außerdem könnte man sagen dass
computerspiele dynamische kunstwerk ist
deren rezipienten zu produzenten werden
also wir gestalten dieses ästhetische
phänomen mit indem wir uns einklinken
zum beispiel durch einen avatar etwas
vollziehen künstlich intelligente ist
auch noch wichtig wird auch mit mehr
teil von computerspielen das heißt unser
spiel verhalten dient als empirische
daten basis für die künstliche
intelligenz im spiel die dadurch immer
besser wird und immer eine größere
herausforderung für uns darstellen
dann hatte ich in einer der letzten
sitzung die anthropologie der
digitalität thematisiert also welche
anthropologischen implikation gehen mit
dem phänomen der digitalität einher wie
verhalten sich andere profi und die
soziale realität zueinander wie
verhalten sich digitalität und trans
humanismus zueinander alle der begriff
des traditionalismus war bis um das
zentrale und hier sind natürlich zwei
begriffe ganz wichtig im kontext der
transnistrischen theorie sage jetzt mal
nämlich singularität als eine folge von
experten ziehe ali t ich hatte dieses
buch von ray kurzweil
vorgestellt singularity ist mir in
humans and biology gibt es dann diese ex
potenziale exponentiellen wachstums
kurve die sehr vorausschauend angelegt
ist also hier geht es bis in das jahr
2100 sie sehen ihr mehr wir uns diesen
jahren wären umso steiler wird die kurve
fast schon wenn man so ein bisschen
weiter denken wäre sie fast schon
senkrechten das natürlich nie möglich
ist bei exponentiellen wachstums hat so
eine gewisse richtung das immer extremer
steigt in diesem extremen wachstum was
irgendwann in der zukunft zumute wird
oder prognostiziert wird muss man ja
genau sagen da in dieser ganz steilen
steigung da ist dann irgendwie ein
phänomen zu erkennen was singularität
genannt wird wo die technik soweit sich
entwickelt dass sie uns menschen in ganz
verschiedenen hinsicht gucken tief
überstand das ist dann die singularität
hier gibt es dann das logo des tanz man
ist - al di meola ried wird heute von
transpondern ist hinter nationalisten
propagiert oder prognostiziert ransmann
ismus von lateinisch trans jeden fall
jetzt über hinaus und romanos menschlich
ist eine philosophische denkt riecht und
die die grenzen menschlicher
möglichkeiten sei es intellektuell
physisch oder psychisch durch den
einsatz technologischen verfahren
erweitern die interessen und werte der
menschheit werden als verpflichtung zum
fortschritt angesehen ransmann ist innen
und run zumindestens sind immer sehr
techno viel sind optimistisch sie
verstehen sich durchaus auch in der
tradition der aufklärung stehen sie
blenden aber so scheint es mir eben zu
sehr die negativen seiten auch die
technik aus und sie ideologisieren sie
und hier hat meine darüber nehmen ein
sehr kleines sehr treffende kritik geübt
an dieser silicon valley ideologie wie
er sie nennt und möchte diese ideologie
einen ja einen vernünftigen rationalen
digitalen humanismus und gegensätzen
also den menschen nicht mehr einfach zum
gegenstand einer technologischen
revolution werden lässt sondern eben an
diesen alten humanistischen menschen
althergebrachten sage jetzt mal nicht
veralteten aber eben auch die
humanistischen antiken da durchaus auch
um menschen begriff ansetzt als
menschenwürde und so weiter und eben
diese menschenwürde verteidigt gegenüber
technokratischen einflüssen wie sie
ebenfalls humanistin traditionalisten
häufig fordern um eben den menschen
angeblich verbessern zu können ja jetzt
möchte ich eben noch mal ein paar
probleme des transfers muss das habe ich
schon getan er extrapoliert auf künftige
entwicklung wir haben gesehen der kurve
stieß jahr 2100 es ist eine lange zeit
und zwar durch analogie und pornos es
geht also um ein analogie schluss sind
immer philosophisch mit vorsicht zu
genießen er orientiert sich der konzern
ist an der biologischen
evolutionstheorie die seien auch
fortschritt bedeutet und erweitert diese
biologische evolutionstheorie durch eine
technologische evolutionstheorie in der
technik und mensch immer mehr
konvergieren also die technologische
evolution löst gewissermaßen die
biologische ab dann nimmt der mensch
seine eigene natur selbst in die hand
franziskus besitzen die man sich denken
kann spekulative züge allein schon
aufgrund der langen zeitlichen dauer
aber natürlich abbauen hand der
phänomene die er postuliert und
ermöglicht annimmt oder auch wenn nötig
an und er besitzt auch ideologische züge
weil es hier immer auf eine verbesserung
des menschen geht also technik wird hier
immer
letztendlich als etwas normativ gutes
angesehen technik rechtfertigt sich
selbst nach den ansätzen des transfers
muss und das kann man natürlich immer
noch kritisieren
müssen auf die anthologie der
digitalität jenseits des trends
humanismus eingehen also anthropologie
der mensch und digitalität stehen in
einem engen verhältnis zueinander also
technik der digitalisierung ist unsinn
der digitalität nichts fremdes die
menschen sondern sie übersteigt eben die
digitalität diese diesen dualismus von
menschen technik oder menschen
erschienen wenn digitalität durch den
begriff der virtuellen realität bestimmt
ist das habe ich habe mehrmals behauptet
dann muss auch die anthropologie vom
begriff der digitalität her verstanden
werden virtuelle realität wird also als
eine dimension existenz weise des
menschen sichtbar die in seiner freiheit
besteht diese freiheit ist eine freiheit
der virtuellen realität und sie erlaubt
es vorhandene und bekannte dinge eine
andere weise neu zu realisieren insofern
steht digitalität im kontext der ganzen
menschheitsgeschichte mit den ersten vor
wissen von virtuellen währungen von
muscheln die plötzlich als andere
realisierung von geld und nicht mehr nur
naturmaterialien gehalten bis hin zu
münzgeld und banknoten und so weiter er
kann also die digitalität in eine schöne
kontinuität zur menschlichen
kulturgeschichte
einbeziehen die nichts fremdes mehr ist
dann haben wir uns noch befasst mit der
politik der digitalität wir haben
diskutiert gibt es ein menschenrecht auf
internetzugang gibt es digitale menschen
rechte und pflichten sollte es eine
globale internet regierung geben das
sind alles fragen die man hier stellen
kann die vielleicht auch gar nicht so
sehr philosophisch sind sollte es eine
globale internet regierung geben was
heißt das genau
interessante oder wichtiger noch die
frage benötigen wir eine digitale
aufklärung falls sie habe ist diese zu
denken und durchzuführen das scheint mir
besonders wichtig zu sagen hier sollte
auf diese sehr lesenswerte buch glaube
aus dem jahr 2013 eingehen digitale
aufklärung warum und das internet klüger
macht dieses buch ist es sein ein
gegenentwurf zu julian von manfred
spitzer der würde eben gerade das
gegenteilige brauchen dann würde ich ihr
schreiben digitale verdummung baum uns
das internet immer macht ja das wäre ein
möglicher titel für die berufe manfred
spitzer hier gibt es ein gegenentwurf
dazu und deswegen möchte ich ihnen eben
auch normal zitieren
sowie die digitalisierung immer
beschleunigung bedeutet bedeutet
vernetzung immer verändert sie liegt
geradezu im wesen der vernetzung bekommt
also digitalisierung ist immer
beschleunigung vernetzung und zur
änderung natürlich ist hier jetzt auch
die these vertreten dass diese
beschleunigung die veränderung immer
auch eine verbesserung oder mal ist es
eine verbesserung bedeutet das muss man
jetzt auch kritisieren weil technik als
solche noch nicht unbedingt moralische
verbesserung bedeuten effizienz bedeutet
nicht moralisch verbesserungen sie kann
dazu dienen sie kann aber auch ganz
anderes gebraucht werden also meine
kritik an diesem buch wäre das auch hier
nicht der begriff die digitalität
zugrunde gelegt wird der begriff der
digitalisierung nur ein technisches
finden und davon lassen sich keine
normative weitgehenden schlüsse ableiten
das ist eben das problem ja jetzt werden
aber dann dennoch zu zehn wirklich gute
thesen
genannt nämlich alles was ich
digitalisieren lässt wird digitalisiert
alles was ich vernetzen lässt wird
vernetzt und das ändert alles dem stimme
ich zu lebens wirklich bedeutung der
digitalisierung
digitalisierung und vernetzung sind kein
schnupfen sind nicht corona kann man
sagen sie gehen nicht wieder weg auch
wenn natürlich corona zur
digitalisierung und vernetzung
beigetragen hat ich glaube auch hier
haben wir einen nächsten schritt gemacht
ebenso wie die elektrizität nicht mehr
loswerden ich hatte ja auf die
philosophie der elektrizität hingewiesen
ganz zu beginn so werden wir auch die
digitalisierung nicht mehr los auch gar
nicht schlimm weil wir wie malteser
lautet immer schon digitalen sind die
virtuellen realität das heißt sie ist
gar nichts fremdes und digitale und
reale welt durchdringen sich immer mehr
dass verändert beide mit rasender
geschwindigkeit und in einem bisher
unvorstellbaren nasen die mir natürlich
auch zu und diese these mit besonders
zentrale these 4 digitalisierung und
vernetzung schachtel technisch und
gesellschaftlich kulturell und
wissenschaftlich neue bedingungen sie
geht es in kategorien zu fassen und als
qualitäten zu verstehen also diese
letzte satz die bauern kategorien für
die digitalisierung zu diesem neuen
phänomene und wir müssen sie qualitativ
verstehen nicht nur quantitativ im sinne
des schneller besser weiter und so fort
das ist genau dieses anliegen dieser
vorlesen gewesen ich habe ja einige
begriffe versucht zu prägen wie zum
beispiel in der objektivität trans
aktivität und ubiquity digitale
mobilität das sind versuche vielleicht
nicht vollkommen aber fürs erste
versuche dieses diese these einzulösen
philosophen start genau also das waren
wirklich sehr lesenswerte thesen wie ich
finde von diesem motto ich habe dann
noch kurz einbezugs immanuel kant
gebracht nämlich wenn man von aufklärern
spricht muss man natürlich sofort auf
immanuel kant eingehen und er hat hier
eine beantwortung der frage was ist
aufklärung sich vorgenommen bereits 184
und hier eben sie kennen diesen satz
alle aufklärung ist der ausgang des
menschen aus seiner selbstverschuldeten
unmündigkeit
bis dahin muss man es nur erst mal lesen
ist es also die unmündigkeit die zum
ausgang genommen wird und das heißt wenn
wir das ganze jetzt beziehen auf die
philosophie der digitalität auf die
digitale aufklärung müssen wir uns erst
fragen wo denn die digitale unmündigkeit
besteht die wir verlassen müssen durch
digitale aufklärung worin besteht sie
meine these ist digitale mündigkeit
besteht darin dass wir alle
informationen im internet zur bahre
mitzunehmen dass wir die entwicklung der
digitalisierung als ein technologisches
phänomen verstehen also eben nicht
qualitative dimension dem entnehmen
können dass wir die digitalisierung nur
als ein instrument benutzen des
äußerlichen dass wir die digitalisierung
als ein die klammer konsum medium
verstehen also passiv der entwicklung
gegenüber stehen dass wir nicht zwischen
simulation physische realität
unterscheiden wenn wir zum beispiel
computerspiele spielen dass wir uns da
ganz
in den sog in bann schlagen lassen und
eben auch nur digitalisierung als ein
konsum medium ansehen und dabei die
realität mit damit vermischen das wäre
eine möglichkeit aber eben auch wäre
eine unmöglichkeit blende nicht zwischen
simulation und virtuelle realität
unterscheiden das scheint mir eben die
zentrale unterscheidung zeit die wir
machen müssen worin besteht dann der
ausgang aus dieser gerade skizzierten
digitalen mündigkeit der ausgang zum
beispiel so aus dass wir das internet
nicht nur als ein bloßes instrument oder
indium verstehen sondern als ein
virtueller handlungsraum die mir nicht
als ein bloßer rezipient eine
rezipienten eine konsumentin ein
konsument entgegen stimmt so indem wir
selbst aktiv werden und unsere freiheit
wir verstehen unsere handel im internet
nicht als bloße simulationen illusion
oder fiktion achter wird schon nichts
passieren wenn ich jetzt dass ihr macht
das ist doch nur fiktion wurde vision
sondern als virtuelle realitäten für die
verantwortung tragen und eine weitere
möglichkeit dieser digitalen
unmündigkeit cent gehen wäre die das
würde digitalisierung nicht als eine uns
beherrschende technik verstehen sind als
einen möglichen grund von freiheit ins
virtuelle realität ich darf hinzufügen
digitale unmündigkeit würde auch darin
bestehen so meine ich bin mir
das internet und die digitale sphäre nur
im sinne der kommerzialisierung
verstehen sie auch da würden wir
unmöglich werden
wir verstehen das internet auch dann im
sinne der aufgeklärten aus des
aufgeklärten ausgangs aus der digitalen
mündigkeit wenn wir es nicht als
spielzeug sind als ein grundbedürfnis
bestehen auf welches alle menschen im
grunde anrecht haben ob dieses recht am
ende durchgesetzt werden kann ist eben
dann eine andere frage leider eben nicht
so viel kann man denke ich sagen es wird
sicherlich nie
objektives mensch gerecht werden können
dass jeder mensch zugang hat dass sie
kleidet die ungerechtigkeit ist groß
aber genauso verhält es sich leider auch
mit wasserzugang bildungszugang und so
weiter meine these wenn alle menschen
internet hätten hätten sie eben zu klein
auch bildungszugang und auch gesundheits
zu kommen damit wäre schon viel geregelt
deswegen sollte man in meinen augen da
zunächst anfangen mit dem internet ja
dann haben wir hier eine politik des
internets kurz skizziert das internet
als virtueller handlungsraum ermöglicht
die für die freiheit die verwirklichung
eben auch von mehreren menschen von
kollektiven warum sollte diese freiheit
nur bestimmten menschen zu kommen in
mitteleuropa kann man sich fragen das
internet ist in sich immer global
strukturiert so scheint mir und sie
verkörpert das es verkörpert die idee
der vereinten nationen auf
paradigmatische weisen deswegen sollte
das internet keine nationalen sind eine
internationale angelegenheit zahl freier
zugang zum internet um demokratie stehen
in einem engen verhältnis also wenn wir
internet als grundrecht durchsetzen
würden das internet weiter verbreiten
sind
wir eben nicht nur bildungszugang sind
eben auch zu meine these eine zunahme
von demokratie und freier
meinungsäusserung kann man das sagen ist
wieder eine ein ideal aber man muss ja
auch immer ideale in der philosophie
vertreten um sie begrifflich dann zu
analysieren und jetzt möchte ich ganz
zum schluss dieses parforce ritt durch
die
vorleser diesem semester noch einen
ausblick geben wie ich ihm versprochen
habe auf die zukunft der digitalität
vieles was wir hier behandelt hatten war
schon ein ausblick auf ich möchte hier
jetzt geben dass mit albers um als
zukunft des internets thematisieren
virtuelle realität als realität und das
onlive als lebensform diese drei punkte
hängen natürlich alle miteinander
zusammen im begriff des metaversum auf
dem möchte ich kurz eingehen in den mal
vorstellen auch hier
bleibe ich gewissermaßen metaversum wenn
ich ihn von wikipedia zitiere wikipedia
zähle ich nämlich auch zum metaversum
auch wenn es sicherlich noch ein recht
rudimentär begriff ist weil hier die
handlungs dimension noch sehr beschränkt
ist ja dass metaversum im schweizer
börse ist ein kollektiver virtueller
raum der durch die konvergenz und
virtuell erweiterter physische realität
und fühlt sich persistent im virtuellen
raum entsteht einschließlich der summe
alle virtuellen welten der erweiterten
realität gruppen die realität und des
internets das wort mit abs und ist ein
koffer wort aus der vor sieben meter in
der beton jenseits und universum begriff
wird üblicherweise rennen um das konzept
einer zukünftigen iteration des
internets zu beschreiben das aus
persistenten gemeinsam genutzten
virtuellen 3d räumen steht die zu einem
wahrgenommenen virtuellen universum
verbunden sind also hier haben wir
wieder die tendenz ins internet geht vom
internet zum internet über also wir
vernetzen immer weitere bereiche
insofern ist das mit der wertung ganz
konsequent weitergedacht
in abgrenzung dazu besteht ein massively
multiplayer online role playing game aus
einer einzigen welt mit aversion können
user die welt mitgestalten und dort das
leben lernen arbeiten und feiern also
hier sehen wir es wird wirklich lebens
wirklich zentral bei ihm ganz
verschiedenen bereiche unserer
lebenswelt unseres alltags damit
vernetzt werden das steht wahrscheinlich
auch nahe zu sein warum sollte ich im
internet nur arbeit und nur spielen wenn
ich alles doch zugleich machen kann also
das ist wieder die tendenzen der jetzt
alles miteinander zu vernetzen auch in
unser leben ja jetzt komme ich hier kurz
auf metall zu sprechen da ist das neue
logo von vormals facebook auch hier
wieder bescheiden aus wikipedia die meta
plattform sync doing business als wetter
ehemals facebook inc ist ein
us-amerikanisches technologieunternehmen
mit sitz in menlo park kalifornien der
gesellschaft gehören unter anderem die
sozialen netzwerke facebook instagram
die instant messaging app whatsapp und
messaging oculus ein hersteller von
virtual reality technologie verzeichnete
das unternehmen im jahr 2010 noch
2,2 1000 127 mitarbeiter bei einem
umsatz von 1,97 milliarden ist sondern
einen jahresüberschuss von 2 606
millionen us-dollar wuchses bis 2020 auf
1970 mitarbeiter bei einem umsatz von
117,9 milliarden us-dollar gewaltiges
wachstum und einem jahresüberschuss von
39 3 7 milliarden us-dollar im februar
2001 an sich ansieht ist schon ein jahr
alt diese statistik erreichte der
börsenwert des unternehmens
766 jan usd man sieht hier von
metaversum zum mittag
es steht hier dahinter ein ganz großes
kommerzielles interesse ein gewaltiger
eine gewaltiges kommerzielles
finanzielles potenzial ja das muss man
immer berücksichtigen wenn man vom
metaversum spricht wer
ermöglicht uns das metaversum
er stellt die infrastruktur den
virtuellen handlungs frauen zur
verfügung das er nie bekommen ärzte
interessierte unternehmen und inwiefern
das zu einer freiheit im virtuellen raum
beitrag muss man immer kritisch doch
momentan ist es jedenfalls so dass wir
nicht von irgendwelchen nationalen oder
internationalen
nations organisation diese infrastruktur
zur verfügung gestellt bekommen soll wir
sind angewiesen auf große unternehmen
wie eben
metalls möchte ich hier noch auf reisen
words eingehen dass sie sehen des
staates von meta das ist so ein phänomen
des metalls vielleicht haben sie schon
gehört auch hier beziehe ich wieder
informationen aus wikipedia heise und
words for money facebook reisen ist eine
freeware schlick virtual reality online
video game wir sind ins team integriert
game creation system development publish
bei meda platforms riecht er ist im ort
schluss quest to close ist diese firma
die diese 3d brillen die virtuelle
realität sprints und er stellt etwas
release in die usa und kanada twitter
user oder und ist ein banales
2008 an invite only be a face jetzt gibt
es hier leider vielleicht haben sie das
gelesen medien kürzlich probleme in
diesem horizon gehört nämlich ethische
probleme und wenn die sticks september
2010 tiroler beta user reporter ab
also begrapscht und horizon girls and
data die jusos pressekontakt medi
spotted this to say that users can
mission verdeckt im herbst vom
interaction with others also in dieser
virtuellen realität
von horizon world gibt es auch ja
übergriffe ja die
offensichtlich als lästig empfunden also
virtuelle übergriffe und deswegen hat
man jetzt hier eine grenze eingeführt um
den sicherheitsabstand den absturz war
und hier ist jetzt wirklich spannend
diese diese übergang von der bloßen
simulation oder fiktion zu virtuellen
realität
deswegen fährt ein ganz interessantes
phänomen das man unbedingt im blick
bleiben sollte auch wenn es natürlich
hier von meta stand und irgendwie doch
noch eine kommerzielle basis hat aber
das sollte uns zu denken geben es ist
also ganz frisch in den nachrichten
können sie mal googeln gewesen dass man
hier drauf reagiert hat auf diese auf
diesem virtuellen handlungsraum diese
virtuellen handlungen die dort vollzogen
wurden auch im moralisch problematische
szenen man könnte natürlich jetzt immer
darüber diskutiert ist es nicht doch nur
eine simulation einer infektion aber
hier wird darauf reagiert und hier
musste edita digitalität auch an sitzen
an solchen konkreten phänomen sie nicht
nur als eine bloße spielerei abtun wie
mir scheint es gibt noch eine
methodologischen ausblick ganz zum
schluss
sollte jetzt philosophie der digitalität
als eine philosophische disziplin
angesehen werden daneben zb
erkenntnistheorie metaphysik ethik
ästhetik ich glaube nicht also ich
glaube dass sich die philosophie der
digitalität gewissermaßen quer zu diesen
disziplinen verhält insofern sie nämlich
jede diese disziplin ethik ästhetik auf
ihre art und weise betrifft anhand von
drei konkreten phänomen darum ging es
bei dieser vorlesung nämlich den
internet der künstler intelligenz und in
computerspielen ich glaube dass man
anhand dieser drei phänomen ganz
verschiedene philosophische disziplin
neu thematisieren motivieren kann beim
internet kann man zb sich die frage in
den raum und zeit stellen internet kann
man sich die frage nach einer virtuellen
handlung stellen einen handlungsraum man
kann politische philosophie als internet
anbinden sie sehen hier kann man alle
philosophische disziplin auf das
internet beziehen oder anhand des
internets verschiedene philosophische
disziplin durchforsten genauso mit der
künstliche intelligenz hier können zb
die ästhetik ansätzen nfc ist haben wir
gesehen andere dinge wir können
computerspiele thematisieren er spielt
die ästhetik der rolle und auch die stl
die ethik wie wir gerade gesehen haben
sehen alles hängt mit allem zusammen und
das scheint mir ein ganz spannendes
philosophisches fällt es sein wo wir in
zukunft noch viele interessante
ergebnisse forscher sehen werden eine
allerletzte bemerkungen glaube dass zu
philosophie der digitalität man auch
eine gewisse kreative fantasie gehört
nicht so kreativ und spekulativen
transfers muss aber ich finde man muss
immer einen schritt voraus denken und
muss dann eben überlegen wie können wir
die zukunft auch philosophisch fassen
die eule der minerva nach jede so eben
nicht nur in der abenddämmerung ihren
flug beginnen wenn alles schon passiert
ist sondern es sollten immer die
technische entwicklung mit reflektieren
und hier würde ich jedem empfehlen
bietet der digitalität einzuführen weil
er eben schon philosophisch handhabbare
und lebens wirklich integrative ist dann
bedanke mich für ihre aufmerksamkeit
überall raum der ganzen vorlesungen die
jetzt doch viele interessante
erkenntnisse wie ich hoffe vermitteln
konnte und wünschte ihr noch eine schöne
vorlesungsfreie zeit